therefore
Hungary is carrying out the largest
humanitarian operation ever of our
history
up to now we have received more than a
million refugees
obviously we ensure them full and equal
access
to our education and Healthcare System
we give incentive to companies in
Hungary in order to encourage them to
employ refugees
and already one thousand and three
hundred schools and kindergartens in
Hungary are enrolling Refugee kids and
Refugee students
believe me it is heartbreaking to see
those torn apart families who are
arriving to Hungary on a daily basis
kids only with their mothers leaving the
fathers behind
based on our experience in the
neighborhood dear colleagues this war
has only brought suffering
and this war has no winners
this war does have only losers
hundreds or even thousands of people are
killed on a daily basis
therefore the most important duty of
International Community should be to
save lives
and of course the question must be
raised how it is possible
how it is possible to save lives of the
people
the answer
it is simply to be said
more complicated to achieve
but the answer is peace
we can save lives of the People by
creating peace
and based on our experience
it became already pretty obvious
that neither delivery of weapons nor
sanctions
those measures do not save lives
to the country
they contribute to the prolongation
and the risk of escalation of this war
and they bring more suffering
that's why Dear Mr President dear
colleagues
Hungary cause on the International
Community
to finally start to concentrate on how
to establish an immediate ceasefire
and how to contribute to launching peace
talks as soon as possible
peace talks which should come to an
agreement
about a sustainable piece in our
neighborhood
and we also know from our sad experience
that
peace can only be reached through
dialogue and discussion
therefore channels of communication must
be kept open
if channels of communication are being
cut then it means that the Hope For
Peace is given up as well
and here Mr President I do believe that
United Nations should fulfill its role
we all know that the United Nations as
an institution or as an organization has
not been created as an integration of
like-minded countries
United Nations have been created to
serve as a platform for dialogue for
those
who even consider each other as enemies
therefore we urge
talks between Russia and the United
States to be started as soon as possible
in the framework of the United Nations
we hungarians I want to underline again
we are living in the neighborhood
and I can imagine that the situation in
Ukraine might seem less serious from
hundreds or thousands of kilometers away
or even from an ocean away
but believe me believe us in the
neighborhood we are pretty much aware
that we are in the 25th hour
and although Hungarian people are
absolutely not responsible for the
outbreak of this war
and although it is not our war but still
Hungary and the Hungarian people have
already paid a very high price for this
war
and Mr President when I say this I do
not only speak about the skyrocketing
inflation
I do not only speak about the extra 10
billion euros which have been added to
our Energy bill within the last year but
I do speak about the high number of
those hungarians
members of the Hungarian community in
Ukraine who have died on the front line
and we do not want any more people to
die
that's why we urge All actors of
international political life to refrain
from decisions measures and statements
which bring the risk of prolongation or
escalation of this war
because I would like to remind all those
big and strong countries
who represent War rhetoric that they
have not lost any lives in this war yet
but we hungarians we definitely did
Dear Mr President you know it very well
we hungarians are living in Central
Europe
and we have understood very clearly
the lesson of History
we all know that whenever there was a
conflict between East and West we in
Central Europe we have always lost
therefore another major east to west
conflict would definitely be against our
national interest
complete Generations in Hungary have
lost decades from their lives because of
the cold war and we do not want to lose
more
we do not want the world to be divided
into blocks again
instead of blocks we want connectivity
and cooperation
and we do not want this Regional War to
become a global one
none of us should forget their
colleagues none of us should forget that
war is always a failure of diplomacy and
peace is always a success of diplomacy
that's why
I hope all of us will multiply our
diplomatic efforts in order to create
peace finally in our neighborhood we
hope that 2023 will be a year of peace
and reconstruction
[Music]
thank you so much for your kind
attention
I thank the Minister of Foreign Affairs
of Hungary customer minister
now I give the floor to
Her Excellency
Minister for Europe and Foreign Affairs
of Albania
Mr President of the general assembly
excellencies
one year ago on this day the world was
holding its breath waiting to see what
choice Russia's president would make
on February 24th we learned that he made
his choice
this war is one for which there was no
other reason than this Choice by the
Russian presidents we should do well to
remember that
Ukraine did not attack Russia Ukraine
did never threaten Russia that claim is
just as ludicrous today when the whole
world has seen the weakness of the
Russian army as it was back in February
23rd of last year when most of the
worlds expected The Invasion to succeed
in a matter of days
it was an unprovoked illegal criminal
invasion of a country it was above all
an act of aggression that clearly
violated the U.N Charter and
international law
one that was condemned in no uncertain
terms and in Landslide votes through a
number of resolutions by this assembly
the international court of justice has
also been very clear in its order of
March 16th of last year stating that the
Russian Federation shall immediately
suspend the military operations on the
territory of Ukraine and it must also
ensure that other forces under its
control are supported by Moscow should
not continue the military operation
it is not just our evaluation of the
military capabilities of the Russian
army that has changed over the past year
the brutality of this Force has become
appearance to all the war crimes it has
committed in Ukraine in this past year
indiscriminate bombings of entire cities
and towns the rapes the executions the
massive enrollment of convicts and
mercenaries are perhaps the best
indictments of the true nature of
Russia's War
just as the truly heroic resistance of
the Ukrainian people has rendered null
any arguments and excuses Russia tried
to present to the world in a vain
attempt to gain legitimacy for its war
of choice
this war has had dramatic consequences
for the entire world but I submit to all
in this assembly that what we have seen
until now is as nothing compared to what
we would see if Russia is allowed to
Prevail in this conflict would anyone
hear any of our countries here be safer
if the U.N Charter and international law
are allowed to be trampled in the manner
Russia has done I believe not I believe
that a world where might makes right
where countries can suddenly decide to
attack their neighbors and Annex parts
of their territory is a world that would
not benefit any one of us or our people
it would practically mean to go back to
the logic of 1930s
that is why Albania fully supports the
resolution U.N Charter principles
underlying a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine that is why we
believe that this assembly must vote in
support of this resolution and make
clear its support for a just peace in
Ukraine in accordance with the
principles of the U.N Charter which
should guarantee the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
extending to its territorial Waters in
the same vein we oppose the Hostile
amendments presented by Belarus they
represent no efforts to contribute to
peace but an attempt to Shield the
aggressor they must be rejected and we
call on all the U.N members to vote no
Albania requests recorded votes on the
two amendments proposed by Belarus a
slash es11 L8 and a slash es11 L9 thank
you
I thank the minister for Europe and
Foreign Affairs of Albania
now I give the floor To Her Excellency
Catherine Colona Minister for Europe and
Foreign Affairs of France
Mr President
ministers their colleagues ambassadors
it's been a year now since Russia
launched its war of aggression against
Ukraine without any justification and
completely illegally
and for the past year it has waged a
brutal War there a war which violates
the most fundamental principles of our
common Charter as well as its own
commitments
this has been a year of War marked by
successive abuses and crimes so serious
and systematic that the international
criminal court has launched
investigations into war crimes crimes
against humanity and genocide
none of us can turn a blind eye to
executions torture
sexual violence as a weapon of War
kidnappings and deportations of children
however Ukraine has been resisting
admirably for a year it is resisting for
its own independence for its freedom and
for its right to build the future it has
chosen
as I stand here before our assembly
I wish to express France's absolute
determination to support Ukraine
so that it can not only resist exercise
its right to self-defense so right
recognized by our common Charter but
also so that it can enforce its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
these are also principles that unite us
I do so so that Ukraine can therefore
thwart Russia's aggression which is a
serious threat to International peace
and stability and therefore to the peace
and security of all of us
this is a matter of concern for all of
our States because there will be no
peace and security anywhere if
aggression is rewarded
this war waged by Russia is therefore
everybody's business because it
threatens the existence of a state
because it represents a domineering and
imperialist plan because it denies the
existence of borders it is everyone's
business as the President of the
Republic Emmanuel macron said from this
Rostrum last September neutrality is not
a possibility because neutrality would
amount to becoming an accomplice of the
aggressor
letting Russia dictate the terms would
be a fatal blow to the international
rules-based order to which we have all
subscribed for 75 years
it would undermine the very foundations
of our collective security
our common duty is to prevent Russian
aggression from being only the first
step towards a period of serious
instability and systemic violence which
would spare no region of the world
and none of us would have any reason to
sleep easy in a world in which a great
power which moreover possesses nuclear
weapons and is a permanent security
council member could at its own
discretion decide to attack its
neighbors
to deprive them of their freedom
Russia is trying to convince some of you
that its attempts to upset the world
order and impose a strength-based order
will work in their favor this is an
illusion the facts bear this out it was
Russia and Russia alone that wanted the
war
its War poses risks to world food
security particularly in the most
vulnerable countries
similarly it has adverse consequences
for most countries of the world
no more war
no more blockades or strain on food or
energy
Mr President
for a year now this assembly has
remained active in the face of this
unacceptable situation five times since
February 24th last year the assembly has
expressed its commitment to the
sovereignty Independence and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine as the fundamental
principles of the United Nations Charter
today's vote must allow us to recall
these rules and principles without which
peace and security would be nothing but
empty words
the draft resolution presented to you
recalls that it is only with the respect
for these principles that strong and
Lasting peace can be built
conversely Russia shows no desire for
peace
and respects no boundaries the only
dialogue it will accept is that which
subjugates the other side in Ukraine as
elsewhere the only piece it accepts is
the Silence of the dead and of ruins
Russia points the finger at others only
to better deceive and absolve itself of
its own crimes
nobody here wants to go to war with
Russia and certainly not Ukraine no one
threatened the security of Russia or
undermines its Integrity no one has used
the same nuclear rhetoric no one but
Russia wanted the tragedy unfolding
before our eyes
Russia can and must stop tomorrow
the international court of justice
demanded this on the 16th of March last
year
the draft resolution that is proposed by
Ukraine is the result of a transparent
and Universal negotiation process
reflecting a clear desire to bring
together a broad consensus around our
common rules and principles those of our
Charter it calls for a just and Lasting
peace that fully respects these
principles as our common interest
demands
faithful to its tradition and its values
France will give this text its full
support
it calls on all states
to act responsibly and do the same thank
you
I thank the minister the Foreign Affairs
of France and now I give the floor to
his Excellency of culture Minister of
Foreign and European Affairs of Slovakia
[Music]
Mr President ladies and gentlemen fellow
ministers
77 years ago the United Nations founding
fathers I'm very proud to say 1014
papanik established this organization
with the AIM
to save future Generations from
atrocities of War
their Vision was simple and
straightforward
to build a world in which every human
being lives in peace in prosperity while
promoting friendly relations and
cooperation among nations
today
we must admit that this Noble mission is
facing a severe challenge
effective multilateralism is falling
apart
with one member state
is blatantly violating fundamental
principles and values of this
organization
the state
or upon which the U.N Charter bestowed
the privilege of guarding these very
principles through the provision of a
permanent seat in the security Council
the Russian Federation
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
we strongly condemn the ongoing
unprovoked and unjustified military
aggression of the Russian Federation
against Ukraine in violation of all
fundamental values and principles of the
U.N Charter and international law
we reiterate our call foreign immediate
cessation of Russian military activities
in Ukraine and demand an unconditional
withdrawal of all Russian troops from
the whole territory of Ukraine
in this regard we would like to Echo the
world's uh words of the Secretary
General who previously said
enough is enough
yet it seems the Russian Federation
obviously does not understand his Appeal
on the contrary
it goes on with its misleading rhetoric
propaganda and the Distortion of facts
on the ground promoting some kind of
alternative reality
it is our duty to take a fierce stand
against these actions in the spreading
of lies and deceptive narratives
the aggression has caused food
insecurity is fueling a global inflation
with devastating impacts mainly on the
most vulnerable countries of the world
millions of ukrainians had to flee their
homes ninety percent of whom are women
and children
Slovakia is one of those countries where
more than hundred thousand of them found
a temporary Refuge
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
today we have gathered here in New York
with one goal
to reaffirm our steadfast commitment to
the values and principles of the UN
Charter
Russia's ignorant attempt at redrawing
internationally recognized borders as a
sovereign country presents a grave
threat not only to Europe
let us be clear
this is not about Ukraine only
whose very existence is questioned today
by one member state
tomorrow
sovereignty territorial integrity and
Independence of any country might be at
stake
this is about effective multilateralism
which is under a severe threat
we cannot afford to let it go to let it
vanish we need it for today and for
future Generations we have all duty to
protect the rule-based world
therefore
I encourage you to vote Yes
for the adoption of the resolution which
Slovakia strongly supports thank you for
your attention
I thank the Minister of Foreign and
European Affairs of Slovakia
now I give the flow to his Excellency
Gordon grillman Minister for foreign and
European Affairs of Croatia
Mr President ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues
it has been a year since the Russian
Federation began to carry out a
so-called special military operation
which is in fact a brutal aggression
against its neighbor Ukraine
we are also very binding that this is an
escalation of aggression which started
in 2014 with Russia's illegal annexation
of Crimea
the fact
is that the Russian Russian against
Ukraine itself blatant violation of
international law
and the unit chartered by a permanent
member of the security Council
and our nuclear weapon state knowledge
is bound to have long-lasting
implication for the UN as a whole
its logic of war and impunity has
brought about events immense human
suffering death and injury of hundreds
of thousands
mass displacements of people and
targeted destruction of Civilian
infrastructure necessary for maintaining
basic needs of life
it's menacing execution brought with his
self-war crimes and crimes against
humanity
while the illegalization of parts of
Ukrainian territory showed cynical
disregard for the U.N Charter itself
finally it has impacted livelihoods
around the globe
as it disrupted the global economic
flows and instigate instigate instigated
worldwide energy and food
security
Euros excellence excellencies
the unprovoked and unjustified
aggression against Ukraine
challenged the very principles of the
Global Security architecture and eroded
the rules-based international order
with profound consequences for yours to
come
we must not stand silent in the face of
those
who destroy and violate the most
fundamental human and Sovereign rights
of states
we owe it to our countries to our
citizens and to all those that will come
after us
if you fail now
not only will our present lugari
but the cause of our failure we pass to
Future Generations
for the same reason we should support
all efforts to establish accountability
for the crimes committed in Ukraine and
we welcome the international court of
justice order seeking the Russian
Federation to immediately suspend its
so-called military operation
excellencies dear colleagues dear
friends
it is the bravery and determination of
the Ukrainian people that stands in the
way of the aggressor
the war in Ukraine sadly resembles the
one in Croatia three decades ago
we
creation unfortunately no to Avail how
this feels
propaganda on the purported need for
densification and protecting protection
of a minority followed by a
self-declared declared Republic on
Croatia soil
Invasion and aggression
however our fight for liberty took for
long years let us not make Ukraine
weight that long for freedom
we stand with Ukraine and its people
we will continue to support them in
their right to defend themselves and to
defend the U.N Charter as well
the global Community also stands with
Ukraine as evidenced by the continuing
support of the vast majority of U.N
member states for General Assembly
resolutions calling foreign end of the
Russian aggression
by standing with Ukraine we are standing
in the fence
of the pillars of our system and
demonstrating our resolve to protect the
U.N Charter
the resolution we are debating today is
a further demonstration of that resolve
creation stands fear in supporting the
territory Integrity Independence and
sovereignty of Ukraine within its
International recognized broaders
knowing that a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace can only be
founded upon these very principles I
thank you
I thank the minister for foreign and
European Affairs of Croatia
now I give the flow to his Excellency
speaking of our Minister for foreign
affairs of Poland
Mr President
Excellence is distinguished delegates
a year has passed since the Russian
invasion against Ukraine started
it has been a year of immense suffering
death and destruction
today
We Gather here to call for peace
the resolution that has been put forward
before the general assembly defines the
steps that needs to be taken to achieve
it
a comprehensive just and Lasting peace
is the only acceptable option to end the
world in Ukraine
it is possible
only when sovereignty Independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine is
reconfirmed
Russia
must immediately completely and
unconditionally withdraw its forces from
the territory of Ukraine within its
internationally
recognized borders
it is a fundamental importance to ensure
Russia's full accountability for the
crimes it has committed in Ukraine
Poland
supports International initiative
towards that end and towards redressing
in an adequate form
all wrongs inflicted by Russia
in this world
today
in light of Russia's total disregard for
international law and the U.N principles
we must reconfirmed our commitment to
the basic rules
of international order
Mr President
Russia continues its brutal aggression
attacking ukrain's civilian population
and non-military infrastructure
committing war crimes and atrocities
including the killing of women and
children
torture
sexual violence
and forcible deportations
standing up against Russia
ukrainians made history themselves
they stood up to tyrannical force with
courage and resilience
they chose
to fight to defend their independence
freedom and identity
more than that they defended the
rules-based international order
the brave Ukrainian Nation
deserves not only our compassion
but also
our support and solidarity
Poland will continue to assist Ukraine
for as long as it takes
in addition to offering shelter to
millions of Ukrainian refugees
Poland keeps providing and facilitating
transfers of aid
we have a main support Gateway for
Ukraine
and we are going to continue this role
as long as it is needed
Mr President
this war
and its outcome matter throughout the
world
Russia's Invasion has contributed to a
sharp increase in fuel
fertilizers and food prices
it caused disruptions of Supply chains
the resulting crisis is especially harsh
on those most vulnerable
there is no doubt that Russia is solely
responsive for this dire situation
for Russia
this war is about its Imperial desires
and ambitions
for Ukraine
it is about defending its inalienable
right to sovereignty and territorial
integrity
for all of us gathered here this war is
about the most fundamental U.N
principles
let us reaffirm the very significance
and our commitment to them
let us not render them irrelevant
it is simply our duty
to support a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine in line with
the UN Charter
thank you
I thank the minister for foreign affairs
of Poland
now I give the floor to his Excellency
yoshima sahayashi Minister for foreign
affairs of Japan
Mr President distinguished colleagues
193 member states in this General
Assembly Hall they present
193 different positions
such diverse view I believe can combust
on one specific point
we all want peace in Ukraine
or at least the overwhelming majority of
us want peace in Ukraine
this draft resolution is about peace
however peace must be based on
principles
hostilities must stop now but this would
not necessarily produce a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace
imagine yourself
what if a permanent member of the
security Council wrote an aggression
against your Homeland
clubs your day tree and then seized
hostages
calling for peace
I would call it an unjust peace
it would be a victory for douglasa if
such actions were tolerated
it would set a terrible precedent for
the last of the planet
the Wildwood livage to the Jungle where
a brute force and question would prevail
Mr President distinguished colleagues
peace must be based on the principles of
the United Nations Charter
that is why Japan supports this craft
resolution entitled principles of the
charter of the United Nations underlying
a comprehensive just and Lasting peace
in UK
I urge my fellow cliques gathered here
today to vote in favor of it
Russia must first and foremost
withdraw its troops immediately and
unconditionally from Ukraine
the general assembly has demanded it as
how the secretary Secretary General and
international court of justice
unfortunately Russia seemingly cannot
care about the general assembly
resolutions and icj orders
as if they were just pieces of waste
paper
in addition abusing the beetle power is
not enough Fellowship it also abuses its
status as a nuclear weapon state with
its illicit possible rhetoric Russia's
nuclear threats let alone any use of its
nuclear weapons shall never be
correlated
Russia should be held accountable for
all of its acts in an appropriate manner
other member states should also reflect
from supporting douglasion is a
directory or indirectly
in this regard the proposed amendments
by Bella Luz are an attempt to destruct
the attention of the member states from
the fact that the Russian aggression is
in violation of the belly principles of
the United Nations Charter
fellow colleagues to vote against the
amendments
Mr President distinguished colleagues my
heart breaks for the diet human Italian
situation of the people who will claim
Japan will continue to provide support
for them
along with fellow members of the
International Community
at the same time we must not forget that
many other people around the world are
suffering as well
natural disasters conflicts violence
terrorism
food and energy crisis climate change
infection diseases the list goes on and
on
we need an integrated and tailored
approach to deal with these issues and
that is what the United Nations excels
at however the U.N is now being tested
it has been damaged
we need to restore trust in this
organization
we need to unite ourselves again
we need to strengthen the entire
organization to Grapple with today's
ever more complex and interlinked
challenges
this will entail not only the form of
the security Council
but also enhanced laws for the general
assembly the Secretary General the
economic and social Council the peace
building commission and other bodies of
the United Nations
is the president distinguished
colleagues next year
we should not meet here to Mark the
second anniversary of this senseless
wall or population
instead we should walk towards peace
Guided by the rule of law
let us meet here for the 2024 Summit of
the future and make it a summit of peace
let us Mark 2024 as a year over
strengthened United Nations
I thank you
I'm the Minister of Foreign Affairs of
Japan
now I give the floor to her exercise
Minister for foreign affairs European
Affairs and foreign trade and the
federal cultural institutions of Belgium
Mr President
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
we did not want this war we wanted to
live in peace respecting the principles
to which the entire International
Community subscribed by adhering to the
United Nations Charter
all of us present here made a commitment
through Article 2 to respecting the
territorial Integrity internationally
recognized borders and to settle our
disputes peacefully
and all of this was flouted by Russia on
February 24th of last year
and no
this is not a war of the West against
Russia
while Ukraine is the first victim
attacked on its territory and threatened
in its very existence it is the entire
International Community which has been
affected and has been shaken because
this aggression undermines the
international order food financial and
energy security
it sews doubts
increases nuclear risk and impacts the
environment
one year after the Russian aggression in
Ukraine the world stands impoverished
and Global Security is threatened
but we are present many of us have
traveled
all the way to New York to call for a
just and Lasting peace
and we wholeheartedly hope that this
resolution
will bring us even closer together
tomorrow because we do not want an
uncertain world where insecurity danger
and threats become the norm because we
want to have confidence in the future
because together we are capable of the
best even in difficult circumstances
thanks to the efforts of U.N agencies in
the Secretary General the Black Sea
Green initiative have enabled has
enabled vital Food Supplies to be
delivered to countries and directly
affected by this conflict we have not
forgotten them just as we have not
forgotten the crises on other continents
some of which
have worsened following Russian
aggression in Ukraine
the misinformation the alternative
truths the false equivalencies and
biased reasoning that our Russian
colleagues have been spreading for
almost a year now are not
backed up by the hard facts the cruel
reality is that we are facing such as
kidnappings displacement or
deportations Justice will find the right
words to describe the suffering of
thousands of Ukrainian children
these cities have been forever marked by
horror
over the past year we have witnessed
Russia's Relentless violations of
international humanitarian and human
rights law
these crimes cannot go unpunished
Belgium reiterates its support for the
investigations carried out by the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court
we strongly advocate for a world where
norms and the rule of law Prevail over
the principle of Might makes right it is
in this spirit that we must Define the
principles of a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace
Belgium fully supports the draft
resolution submitted to us which was
drafted in an inclusive and transparent
manner
it is a moment of truth that is bringing
us together today to tell the truth
between Belgium joins the large number
of those who call for the immediate
complete and unconditional withdrawal of
all the military forces of the Russian
Federation from Ukrainian territory and
for a return to the internationally
recognized borders of Ukraine
going forward and until peace has
attained Belgium will support Ukraine
for as long as necessary to preserve the
full meaning of the concept of
collective security which is at the
heart of the United Nations Charter and
at the heart of Peace thank you
I thank
the distinguished Minister of Belgium
now I give the floor to his Excellency
Young
Minister for foreign affairs of czechia
Mr President
we are meeting one years
since the start of Russia's brutal war
against Ukraine to yet again resolutely
defend the U.N Charter and promote
International Peace and Security in line
with the United uniting for peace
resolution
we are horrified by Russia's blatant
violation of international order
the U.N Charter is binding upon all
member States including Russia
Russia must immediately completely and
unconditionally we do its forces and
Military commitment from the entire
territory
of Ukraine within its internationally
recognized border
stands with Ukraine and remains
committed to supporting Ukraine's wish
for a just peace in line with the U.N
Charter
Russia's aggression is causing
unspeakable suffering in Ukraine and
Beyond
it has sent a Shockwave into the world
food and Community Markets and is
threatening to drive 50 million people
on the edge of famine across Africa and
other continents
we support the Black Sea grain
initiative and the UNF Force to achieve
its further extension in March 2023 we
cherish unaction actions which address
why the consequences of the Russia
inflicted War including Global Food
security
we command the Secretary General for his
rentless efforts to stop Russia's
aggression and restore respect for the
U.N Charter
we appreciate the peaceful mura
presented by president zielinski let me
be clear Russia malicious ambitious goes
far beyond Ukraine it was to change the
international order Russia's once a
world defined by spheres of influence
with neocolonial relationship instead of
Partnerships on equal footing
our region Central Europe has had its
own tragic experience with Russia's
aggressive Imperial policy for the sake
of restoring International Peace and
security it is essential to say no to
Russia's imperialistic scheme
all of us should be aware that any
country can be the next Russia's victim
the future of the international order is
being determined now
Ukraine is not only defending itself and
its princip and its people it is also
defending the fundamental principles of
the U.N Charter
efforts to legitimize the use of force
for achieving geopolitical goals and
normalized practices such as Food
Supplies blackmail or nuclear
subrattling must be decisively rejected
Russia's massive abstracts deliberately
conducted in densely populated areas are
destroying civilian infrastructure and
innocent lives
the findings of the U.N Commission of
inquiry are shocking documenting sexual
violence and torture youth as Russia's
tactics of War
we are greatly concerned about the
continuing attacks of the Russian Armed
Forces around Ukraine nuclear sites and
the illegal seizure of zaporosia nuclear
power plant
full accountability for war crimes and
all other crimes in connection with
Russia's war must be ensured including
accountability for the crime of
aggression
letting the leadership responsible for
the crime of aggression go unpunished
would mean giving up on the fight
against impunity and fueling aggression
I'm strong proponent of creating a
special Tribunal for the crime of
aggression against Ukraine even though
it is a complex task
I strongly believe that there should be
also be a U.N involvement to ensure
maximum legitimacy and support
the humanitarian of the world is
heartbreaking
Russia's barbaric full-scale War brings
back a horrors of the second World War
entire towns and Villages have been
damaged and destroyed critical civilian
infrastructure deliberately destroyed in
the middle of the Savage winter people
are trying to escape from Russian bombs
and survive in temporary shelters
the war has forced over 8 million
ukrainians to flee abroad
in the spirit of solidarity Shakira has
opened its doors
almost half a million of them have been
granted temporary protection in my
country most of them women and children
we Remain the country hosting the
highest number of Ukraine refugees per
capita even though it brings some
challenges for the state and our
citizens especially at the time of
Economic and energy crisis our country
and people have demonstrated and
unprecedented wave of solidarity
we have also provided humanitarian
assistance to Ukraine through in-kind
and material support so that people
affected by the war in freezing
temperatures have access to health care
drinking water electricity and heating
here I would like to
stress that our assistance to Ukraine
does not affect our humanitarian Aid nor
budget when helping other countries in
need
Mr President my country strongly
supports the draft resolution put to our
consideration
it defends the principles of sovereign
equality
and territory Integrity of states
I would like to appeal to all those who
might be tempted today to take a neutral
stance and to those who believe that it
is not their War
if you don't act now we are accepting a
new international order based on use of
brutal force based on colonialism
thank you very much
I thank the Minister of Foreign Affairs
of czechia
now I offer the floor to his accency
gabrielius landsbergis Minister for
foreign affairs of Lithuania
[Music]
Mr Secretary General of the United
Nations Mr President of the general
assembly
ministers ambassadors ladies and
gentlemen
one year ago at the dawn of 24 February
Russia aided by its accomplished Belarus
cited its unprovoked unjustified illegal
and blood Invasion against its peaceful
and Democratic neighbor Ukraine
this was not the start of the war which
Russia wages since 2014 when it
illegally occupied Crimean parts of
eastern Ukraine neither was it the first
time Russia attacked its neighbors
the crime of aggression was immediately
followed by war crimes crimes against
humanity and other large-scale systemic
violations of international law that
have caused a humanitarian and human
rights catastrophe with far-reaching
consequences across the globe
the global food security crisis multiple
crisis in nuclear security and safety
energy Finance environment as well as a
direct threat to the preservation of
cultural heritage are all direct
outcomes of Russia's aggression
we are appalled by the harrowing
evidence of atrocities amounting to
genocides committed by the Russian armed
forces and cremated back Mercenaries
wide-scale destruction of cities and
critical infrastructure Mass civilian
casualties forcible transfers of
ukrainians to Russia abductions and
illegal adoption of Ukrainian children
abuse of prisoners of War torture sexual
violence all bear witness to the moral
Abyss into which the aggressor Has
Fallen
these brutal atrocities are a clear
expression of Russia's total disregard
for the core U.N Charter principles of
sovereignty territorial Integrity
international human rights and
international humanitarian law
over the past year Ukraine and its
people have shown remarkable courage and
resilience in defending not just their
own country but the whole rules-based
International order
we applaud Ukraine's heroic defensive
effort that succeeded in stopping the
advancement of invading forces and
destroying the myth of Russia's military
invincibility
the United Nations has demonstrated
significant solidarity as the
overwhelming majority of its membership
condemned Russia's aggression as a
blatant violation of the U.N Charter and
in resolution after resolution demanded
for its unconditional withdrawal
this assembly also stripped Russia off
its seat on the U.N Human Rights Council
declared stage annexation referendums
illegal and took important first steps
towards the international mechanism for
Russia's reparations to Ukraine
the efforts of the U.N Secretary General
were instrumental in sending much-needed
Ukrainian grain to those in need and un
established independent International
Commission of inquiry now investigates
Russia's war crimes in Ukraine
the International Community also came up
with much needed Aid
Lithuania is proud to be among the first
to provide military assistance grant
protection to tens of thousands of
ukrainians and give humanitarian relief
the whole Lithuanian nation is behind
this effort with private citizens and
businesses welcoming ukrainians to their
own homes and donating over 40 million
euros to support Ukrainian armed forces
from basic needs to combat drones and
multifunctional radar stations
however none of that is sufficient to
stop Russia's War
while Russia engages in blame games and
accusations its real objective is to
create spheres of influence instability
and domination
spheres that hark back to Colonial times
which this organization was so
determined to leave behind forever
Russia continues its aggression because
we allow it to act with impunity
as the U.N security Council remains
effectively Paralyzed by Russia's abuse
of its veto the role and responsibility
of the U.N General Assembly becomes ever
more important
we the member states should rise up to
the challenge by supporting president
zielinski's peace formula that firmly
rests on the principles of the U.N
Charter and the rules-based
international order
first and foremost we must demand full
withdrawal and Export expulsion of the
invading forces from all occupied
territories of Ukraine and should not
shy away from supporting Ukraine's
decisive military action
second we must seek full accountability
of the perpetrators
in this regard we welcome the efforts by
the international criminal court
Regional bodies and individual states
who prosecute those responsible for war
crimes crimes against humanity and the
crime of genocide in Ukraine
at the same time since international
criminal court will not have the
jurisdiction over the crime of
aggression we call on this assembly to
mandate an establishment of the special
tribunal to prosecute the crime of
aggression and provide the tribunal with
International legitimacy and cross
Regional support
third we should explore all means to
ensure that Russian assets are used to
compensate for all material and moral
damages caused by the aggression we
welcome the first steps this assembly
has taken towards allowing the victims
of Russia's crimes to exercise their
right to reparation
Mr President dear colleagues with
today's draft resolution that Lithuania
is co-sponsoring we aim to support and
encourage all efforts from for a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
line with a United Nations Charter
it is essential that United Nations
membership remains together with Ukraine
and stands up against aggression and
speaks out in defense or sovereignty and
territorial integrity at the end of the
day that is the only way we can defend
the relevance of the United Nations
Charter and this organization
foreign
Affairs of Lithuania
now I give the floor to his Excellency
boyar usmani
it's there for foreign affairs of North
Macedonia
Mr President
esteemed excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
precisely one year ago the unthinkable
happened
war of aggression in Europe
in the 21st century after Decades of
carefully and skillfully crafted
International order based on rules and
principles
this very organization was created and I
quote to save succeeding Generations
from the scourge of War unquote
now when the people of Ukraine suffer
from the scourge of unprovoked
unjustified and deliberate war of
aggression this organization should
raise its voice clearly and loudly
through representatives of sovereign
member states both in solidarity and in
condemnation
in solidarity because today it is
Ukraine
tomorrow it could be any of our states
who rely on the norms and principles of
international law and consider the
charter of the United Nations as the
undisputable guarantee for their
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity
condemnation because it's not acceptable
that anyone and not talk about the
permanent member of the security Council
a supposed guardian of peace and
stability in the world and under any
circumstances and pretext possible
invades a sovereign state destroy its
infrastructure and infringes unbearable
suffering to the civilian population
we cannot allow or admit
the territorial conquest and changes of
borders by War
neither ridiculously staged referenda on
thus occupied territories
we cannot accept the return of spheres
of influence rule of force and the right
of the strongest to decide the destiny
of other nations
my country North Macedonia voiced this
principal position from the first day of
aggression
for us it is not and has never been a
question about simply taking a side
between the two belligerents because it
is not what really happens
is the Russian Federation by violating
the U.N Charter that deliberately choses
the wrong side of the history
the majority of the member states of the
UN have clearly acknowledged this
regretful fact by voting previous
relevant resolutions from this 11th
emergency special session of the general
assembly
we urge Russia once again to end this
senseless war and withdraw its troops
from The Sovereign territory of Ukraine
the immense damage has already been done
and every additional day of aggression
only further exacerbates human
sufferings
excellencies in 2022 Russia decided to
violate one of the most basic principles
of international law and launched a
fully fledged war of aggression against
Ukraine a U.N founding member State and
neighbor this has shattered the peace
and installed insecurity and uncertainty
the food and energy in security
worldwide are only some of the direct
consequences of this aggression but the
biggest danger lies in challenging the
whole rule-based International order
the International Community embodied in
the United Nations can't afford that
this gross violation of all norms and
principles goes without response
Justice and accountability are needed
for the sake of the victims in the first
place but they are also prerequisites
for avoiding further aggressions and
unprovoked use of force in international
relations
North Macedonia subscribe to this Demand
by supporting the ICC Prosecutor's
investigation of war crimes and crimes
against humanity committed in Ukraine
Additionally the whole international
human rights mechanism should be
implemented in fighting impunity and
holding accountable those responsible
for the war crimes and other violations
of international humanitarian law or
abusing human rights
the adoption of the unga resolution is
of Paramount importance in this regard
my country figures among the initial
co-sponsors and joins other members of
the International Community in a common
Endeavor to restore peace and to
safeguard the rules-based international
order
that wouldn't be possible without
ensuring full accountability for
wrongdoings what is there at stake is no
less than a vision of a world we want to
live in either we will secure peaceful
coexistence and cooperation among
nations free from menaces of war and
aggression or we will be forced to live
in constant fear instability and
uncertainty it's up to each and every
one present in this August assembly to
decide on behalf of the Nations we
represent
excellencies ladies and gentlemen as of
first of January this year
North Macedonia assumed the
chairpersonship of the OIC
the largest regional security
organization in the world
the Russian aggression against Ukraine
erodes also the foundation of this
organization by violating the provisions
of the Helsinki Final Act
I visited Ukraine in my first trip
abroading capacity of the osce chair
if I saw the devastating consequences of
War
I visited the replace civilians in the
camp nearby and while talking to them I
asked myself what did these innocent
civilians most of them elderly people or
children do wrong to deserve this
destiny
and more what we as International
Community could do more than
humanitarian assistance to alleviate
these unsupportable human sufferings
at the end of the day as the motto of
our chairpersonship with the osce says
it's about people
what is the sense of our political
actions nationally and internationally
if we stay idle in front of human
sufferings caused not by natural
disasters but by deliberate war of
aggression accountability today is a
more moral imperative as it is the most
effective means to avoid this happening
again in another place to another
sovereign state to another people
at one point the war will end the
infrastructure will be restored the
houses rebuild but the victims of this
senseless aggression deserve more they
deserve justice
and Humanity deserves a more solid and
anchored base for avoiding the wars of
aggression in the future accountability
is not an objective person but it is in
my sincere View the indispensable tool
to secure peace
stability and security worldwide and to
really save succeeding Generations from
the scourge of War I thank the president
of the general assembly for convening
this session and I thank all of you for
your attention
I thank the minister for foreign affairs
of North Macedonia
I now offered the floor to his
Excellency
Mr phone Affairs of the Netherlands
[Music]
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
tomorrow we Mark a sad one year Universe
anniversary
the anniversary of Russia's illegal
invasion of Ukraine
a war for which Russia and Russia alone
is responsible
over the past year we have witnessed how
Russia's aggression is slowly destroying
Ukraine
our innocent man women and children are
being killed
our schools hospitals
an entire neighborhoods are being wiped
out
and how do Ukrainian people are enduring
murder rape torture and abduction
but make no mistake
this war is not only an attack on
Ukraine
it is an attack
on the principle of sovereignty
it is an attack on the U.N Charter
you and Charter all of us have signed
an attack on our security our economies
and on the sdgs that were already in
jeopardy
it is an attack
on all we stand for
despite all of our differences
and if we turn a blind eye
to Russia's aggression
if we allow it
to trample the U.N Charter
if might becomes right
then I can only see more hardship
more instability and more suffering
ahead of us
ladies and Gentlemen The Only Way
Forward
The Only Way Forward
is to commit to the agreements we have
made
by making sure that Ukraine survives as
a state within its internationally
recognized borders
and by working for a real just and
Lasting peace for Ukraine
that is our common responsibility
and that is why the Netherlands is doing
all it can to support Ukraine
and we will do everything
we will do everything in our power to
ensure
that Russia is how to account
and the justice will be done
we're taking a leading role in this for
a very reason that all of us here should
not accept a world where Brute Force
reveals our Justice
and that is why we strongly support the
Ukrainian prosecutor General and
international criminal court
that is why we will be sending two more
forensic investigation teams in 2023
and that is why we will host a new
international center for the prosecution
of the crime of aggression
and it damages register in The Hague
ladies and gentlemen
we all want peace
and the road to peace is actually very
simple
this war can end today
if Russia sends its Soldiers Home
just send them home
but while this war continues
and as long as it continues
the Netherlands will do all we can to
help Ukraine
and we call on you
we call on all of you dear friends
to join us
to underline our commitments our joint
commitments to the U.N Charter
to the rules-based order it presents
and to vote Yes
to vote Yes on the resolution that is
proof that is put in front of this
assembly today thank you
[Music]
sir for foreign affairs of the
Netherlands
now I give the floor to his Excellency
Edgars rinkovic
Minister for foreign affairs of Latvia
Mr President a year ago
Russia started its brutal Invasion
against Ukraine
latia stands together with Ukraine
against this senseless War
lattice stands for justice not here
stands for just peace
we condemn in the strongest possible
terms Russia's unprovoked large-scale
aggression against Ukraine enabled by
Belarus
Russia's actions are driven by its
Imperial and Colonial ambitions they
undermine the rules-based international
order rooted in the United Nations
Charter
we are witnessing blatant disregard for
the international law
as a nuclear power Russia continues to
use irresponsible nuclear rhetoric only
this week Russia suspended its
participation in the new Star treaty a
permanent member of the United Nations
security Council attempts to change
borders of another sovereign country by
the use of military force permanent
members of the security Council have a
particular responsibility to maintain
International Peace and security
every sovereign country has a right to
choose its own foreign policy course it
applies to Ukraine as well as to any
other country
Ukraine has a right to defend itself
against foreign aggression Ukraine
fights for its survival its right to
exist
the sole responsibility for the world
lays on Russia Russia started this war
and Russia alone can and must end it
immediately
I address the people of Russia Ukraine
did not attack you NATO did not attack
you it is your own government
that attacked Ukraine it as your
soldiers that are killing peaceful
civilians in Ukraine you can stop this
war and you must do so
Russia must leave Ukraine
that is strongly condemns deliberate
attacks by Russia against civilian and
critical infrastructure in Ukraine
residential areas schools kindergartens
hospitals and critical energy
infrastructure are destroyed by Russian
bombings
innocent civilians including children
are killed
more than 17 million people have been
forced to leave their homes orfully
their country the International
Community must continue to provide all
necessary support to Ukraine including
military and humanitarian
library's assistance to Ukraine has
significantly exceeded one percent of
our GDP
the provided support will set the pace
for further construction process in
Ukraine Latvia has engaged in the
Reconstruction of China region
horrific crimes in Ukraine remind of the
bitter experience of Latin people during
the Soviet occupation we condemn the
illegal deportation of Ukrainian
civilians to Russia and first illegal
adaptation of Ukrainian children we
condemned the first hospitalization and
conscription to the rational forces of
the Ukrainian citizens Russia must stop
violating International humanitarian law
and human rights
crimes committed by Russia cannot and
will not go unpunished we commend
efforts of the international criminal
court to investigate atrocity crimes and
to serve Justice for victims regrettably
the international criminal court and
National Judicial Systems cannot
exercise jurisdiction to prosecute the
crime of aggression
what we occurs for establishment of ad
hoc tribe you know under the auspices of
the United Nations this will grant the
tribunal strong International legitimacy
and provide a basis for applying
exceptions from the personal immunities
those in Russian leadership responsible
for crimes must be held accountable
Mr President
a Russian propaganda seeks to justify
its legal Invasion and to deny its
crimes it tries to shift the blame for
Global consequences of this war
we must resist such disinformation with
truths and facts those Russian
individuals and groups engaged in
propaganda in support of Russia's
segregation against Ukraine must be held
accountable
to counter this information that we will
continue to support Independent Media
Russia's war against Ukraine has caused
serious long-term geopolitical economic
and humanitarian consequences far beyond
Europe
food and energy are instruments in
Russia's Warfare affecting people
globally it is Russia's war against
Ukraine that has caused shortage of food
supplies and the rise of energy prices
not the sanctions recommended Black Sea
through an initiative which must be
continued we support the work of the
world food program
last year the Latin government decided
to unblock the Russia's fertilizers in
latterism ports fertilizers are to be
donated to countries of the global South
to improve food security worldwide
Mr President
we welcome president zielinski's ten
point peace formula and strongly support
his vision for peace that rests on the
principles of the United Nations Charter
a Russian must withdraw its forces from
the entire territory of Ukraine I call
on all members of the United Nations to
support the principles of sovereignty
and territorial Integrity I urge member
states to vote in favor of the
resolution for just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
may this year mark a victory over
tyranny cruelty and sufferings thank you
very much
I thank the minister for foreign affairs
of Latvia
now I give the floor to his Excellency
Ignacio Cassis head of the federal
department of Foreign Affairs of
Switzerland
um
thank you Mr presidents
for a year now ladies and gentlemen we
have all been witnessing the serious
violations that the United Nations
Charter in Ukraine for a year now
Russia's military aggression against
Ukraine has continued
in defiance of international law
for a year the trust and the security
order that has prevailed in Europe have
been under threat
every country in the world has been
affected in some way by the
repercussions of this war
consequences are disastrous
the human cost is impossible to quantify
in addition to the thousands of dead
wounded and missing on the ground more
than 8 million people
have had to flee their homes 8 million
this represents the entire population of
my country Switzerland
last year I saw with my own eyes the
destruction and suffering in and around
Kiev
all of us here now
have the names
the name the names and the inhuman
images of bucha crematorius
and her son in our minds
these Horrors
are taking place as we are about to
commemorate these 75 years of the Geneva
conventions next year
with these conventions
we wanted to raise the law above
barbarism
including International humanitarian law
we wanted to turn the page on the
experiences of past Wars
this assembly
has repeatedly stated that such Wars
must never happen again
the Russian military aggression against
Ukraine shows us once again
that we are not safe
a permanent member of the security
Council has decided to attack its
neighbor
an independent and Sovereign Nation
but let us not give up
that would be a serious mistake it would
be a Vindication of all forces seeking
power
no matter how they use it
Mr President
with the resolution submitted to the
vote today we are sending a strong
message of peace
and respect for the law and the
principles that unite us
Switzerland strongly condemns the
serious violations of humanitarian and
human rights law committed in Ukraine
and I call on the entire International
Community here today to work side by
side towards a peaceful resolution of
this conflict
ukrainians
have the right to live in peace
a piece built on the fundamental
principles of international law
such as the prohibition of the use of
force
territorial integrity
and National sovereignty
Switzerland is ready to play its part
let us together reaffirm the importance
of the United Nations Charter at a time
when major challenges require urgent
Global Solutions consider energy
shortages food and security inflation
climate change
and migration
these challenges remind us
that we all depend on each other
they remind us of our responsibilities
turning in word is not a solution
Reddit strengthen our ties mend the
cracks in our institutions and restore
our mutual Trust
finally we must allow the Ukrainian
people and all the peoples of the world
who have been struck by War
to regain hope
and live in peace
our Unity is critical thanks to ongoing
efforts such as the Black Sea Green
initiative some of the negative
consequences of the war have been
mitigated
on the human security political and
economic fronts
Switzerland is providing humanitarian
Aid hosting refugees and has launched
the Reconstruction process in Ukraine
last summer in Lugano
but more needs to be done for example in
the area of humanitarian needs and above
all demining
my country will continue to support
Ukraine while not forgetting other
conflicts around the world
on Monday for instance I will be hosting
a pledging conference for Yemen in
Geneva with my Swedish counterpart
Mr President
by supporting this resolution on Ukraine
today
on the eve of the first anniversary of
the war
we are sending a clear message
in favor of the UN Charter
expectations are high ladies and
gentlemen
let us not disappoint those who are
counting on us
whether in Ukraine in Russia
or in any other country I thank you
I think the federal Minister of
Switzerland
now I give the floor to his Excellency
Deputy Minister for foreign affairs of
Bulgaria
Mr President of the general assembly
Mr Secretary General excelsis ladies and
gentlemen
Bulgaria Alliance itself with the
statement delivered on behalf of the
European Union yesterday
a year has passed since the start of the
Russian federation's unprovoked and
unjustified war of aggression against
Ukraine
a war which is not only in Gross
violation of international law and of
the principles of the Iran Charter but
has seriously damaged Global Security
and stability and has caused and
continues to cause immense suffering
during this year the general assembly
has consistently come together
to stand again this despicable Act of
aggression and against the violation of
the unchart
together we need to continue to fiercely
defend the principles of the UN Charter
international law and the rules-based
order because they are our only
guarantee for peace
I reiterate once again Bulgaria is
unwavering support for the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
including within its territorial Waters
we stand to decline and we will not
recognize Russia's attempted annexation
and illegal referenda
we demand that the Russian Federation
immediately sees its military actions
and unconditionally withdraw all its
forces and military equipment from the
entire territory of Ukraine
Mr President
Russians who have aggression has
resulted in thousands of casualties and
injured massive displacement of
civilians catastrophic destruction of
critical civilian infrastructure
Bulgaria is deeply concerned with the
continued worsening humanitarian
situation
we call for respect of international
humanitarian law and unimpeded
humanitarian access
Bulgaria as all other EU member states
has kept and will continue to keep its
borders open to everyone fleeing the
wine Ukraine without any discrimination
we'll continue to provide humanitarian
assistance on the ground via different
humanitarian actors including Archer
UNICEF and IC RC
the global food crisis that the world
faces today
initially triggered by climate changes
conflicts the pandemic consequences has
been very significantly aggravated by
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine
Bulgaria will do its part to mitigate
the most immediate consequences of this
crisis and will continue to work for
fighting long-term Solutions
we welcome the Black Sea grain
initiative and the leadership of the
Secretary General in restoring the grain
exports from Ukraine's black seaports
while acknowledging that the situation
remains very critical and the need for
humanitarian assistance to a number of
countries in the global South persists
we call for the renewal of the Black Sea
grain initiative in March and for its
unimpeded implementation
Mr President the Russian Federation
Bears full responsibility for its
aggression and all the distraction and
loss of life indeed must it will be held
accountable in accordance with
international law
only through ensuring justice for all
victims will stand
a chance to prevent such crimes in the
near future
excellencies
today the general assembly-based
historic responsibility responsibility
to stand for the principles of the Union
chapter to stand for peace for
international
rules-based dollar
Bulgaria is proud to have co-sponsored
draft resolution principles of the
chapter of the United Nations underlying
a comprehensive Jazz and plastic piece
in Ukraine as it stands for peace
its purpose is to help bring this
coughing to an end and to reaffirm our
Collective support for the international
principles upon which a comprehensive
just
and Lasting peace must be based I urge
all of you to vote in favor of the draft
resolution in front of us
I would like to thank the Ukrainian
people for their extraordinary carriage
and resilience
and finally I rated it once again
bulgaris and wavering support for the
efforts of Ukraine to achieve a lasting
peace in line with the United Nations
chapter and the international law thank
you for your attention thank you
[Music]
I thank the deputy Minister for foreign
affairs of Bulgaria
and now I give the floor to his
Excellency Peter Burke minister of State
for European Affairs and defense of
Ireland
president Ireland aligns itself with the
statement of the European Union
president
we meet today to mark one year since
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
a year of horrific debt and destruction
caused by Russia's illegal and
unjustified War
let us be clear
this invasion was unprovoked and
entirely of Russia's making
let me also be clear
Ireland will continue to stand fully
with Ukraine and its people in the face
of this brutal Russian aggression
president
this year and this war have been marked
by Russia's blatant disregard for human
life
for the U.N Charter
for Border international law including
International humanitarian law
Russia has rooked to see targeted
civilians and civilian infrastructure
seeking to starve and freeze the people
of Ukraine into submission
Russia's War has seen the deaths of tens
of thousands of ukrainians men women and
children
it has forced over 13 million people to
flee their homes in search of safety
over 8 million refugees mostly women and
children have sought protection across
Europe
over 5 million people have been
displaced within Ukraine
Millions more have been forcibly
deported to Russia and held in
contravention of international law
yes
despite all of this
Ukraine remains steadfast in its
resistance and the defense of its
Democratic principles
this war
has also seen a generation of Russian
youth sacrificed to President Putin's
imperialist fantasies
president
this is a war of choice
just as Russia chose to start this war
they can choose to end it
we strongly support the tireless efforts
by the un's Secretary General as well as
by Ukraine itself to bring an end to
this conflict
and for a comprehensive just and Lasting
peace
based on the principles of the UN
Charter
president
the effects of Russia's War are being
felt across the world
Russia's actions have seen the world's
most vulnerable people suffer from
increased food and economic insecurity
with the rising cost of energy and
commodities
Ireland and the European Union are
responding to the global effects of
Russia's census War including through
the EU solidarity lands and the team
Europe response to Global Food
insecurity
we will continue to stand with the
people of Ukraine and the most
vulnerable around the world
we support the Black Sea grain
initiative which must be continued to
allow life-saving grain to reach those
who need it
president
this is a war that has seen Reckless
Russian attacks on nuclear facilities in
Ukraine
a year of threats by Russia to use
nuclear weapons on those that might come
to Ukraine's Aid
it is regrettable and worrying
in disregard that Russia has now chosen
to suspend its participation with the
U.S under the new start treaty
president
Ireland remains fully committed to the
sovereignty
Independence
unity and territorial Integrity of
Ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
those borders have not changed and
Russia's use of force will not change
them
Ireland calls on the Russian Federation
to immediately cease hostilities and
unconditionally withdraw from the entire
territory of Ukraine
we call on the Russian Federation to
refrain from further threats or the use
of force of any kind including nuclear
weapons against Ukraine or any other
member state which could have serious
implications beyond the region
Russia's actions are not just a threat
to Ukraine
they're a threat to the entirety of the
UN membership
every state relies on the rules-based
international order
for their prosperity
for their independence for their
sovereignty
if we fail to hold Russia accountable
if we fail to respond to their attack on
the U.N Charter
we will leave the world in a more
dangerous place for us all
president
the International Community
and the general assembly have repeatedly
made clear its condemnation of this war
including through this special
resolution
as we mark this anniversary
with no end to Russia's war in sight a
further resolution has been put to the
general assembly calling for a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
line with the principles of the charter
of the United Nations
we call on all member states to support
this resolution thank you
I thank the minister of State for
European Affairs and defense of Ireland
now I give the floor To Her Excellency
Joanna sumovuary
state Secretary to the minister for
foreign affairs of Finland
Mr President
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
a year ago in the early hours of 24th of
February we woke up to a new Grim
reality
Russo had launched a brutal full-scale
invasion of its Sovereign neighboring
country Ukraine
Russia's unprovoked and unjustified
aggression against Ukraine was a turning
point
for the past years Russo has been
turning away from cooperation and
rule-based international order
the illegal annexation of Crimea
and the war in eastern Ukraine that
started in 2014 changed our perception
of Russia
yet most of us could not imagine a full
full-scale War
it is important to remember that the
path of dialogue and diplomacy was
always an option
that was not the path Russia took
war and destruction were Russ's choice
Mr President your excellencies it is
appalling to see a permanent member of
the U.N security Council disregard its
obligations for maintaining peace and
security
instead we are witnessing a flagrant
violation of international law and the
U.N Charter and commonly agreed
principles
Russia's methods of warfare in Ukraine
systematically violate international law
most notably the laws of war
Russian missiles have targeted Ukrainian
civilians and infrastructure causing
immeasurable damage and suffering
the attacks have destroyed hospitals
maternity Wards schools kindergartens
and places of worship
testimonies from Ukraine and the areas
liberated from the Russian occupation
tell the gruesome tale of torture extra
judicial executions and sexual violence
our message is loud and clear we must
hold Russell accountable for its
violations of international law
including repatriations for damage
we must ensure that there is no impunity
for atrocity crimes committed in Ukraine
it is not only morally imperative but
it's our right and our duty to do so
Mr President
Russ's war of aggression against Ukraine
has serious consequences and causes
human suffering not only in Ukraine but
also globally
Finland continues to provide political
defense humanitarian and financial
assistance to Ukraine and its people
Global ramifications of the war include
food and energy crisis and Finland
continues to support Global Community to
alleviate negative consequences of
Russia's actions we also support the
implementation of the Black Sea grain
agreement
Mr President today the general assembly
is going to decide on a resolution on
principles of comprehensive lasting and
just peace in Ukraine
the resolution is about Ukraine but it's
also about all of us
wouldn't your country expect support
from the United Nations from all of us
if your country would be invaded and
part of it annexed by by a neighbor
wouldn't you be disappointed if you did
not get support from others
I also want to underline that according
to the U.N Charter if a member state of
the UN is attacked it has an inherent
right of self-defense both individually
and supported by other member states
wouldn't your country seek support in
such distress
Mr President Your Excellence is
finland's support for Ukraine and its
people remains firm we also support
president zielinski's peace initiative
and its implementation
to achieve comprehensive lasting and
Trust peace Russell must immediately end
its brutal and illegal invasion of to
Ukraine We call we call on Russia to
respect the independence and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine to stop missile
strikes on Ukrainian cities and we throw
its forces from the territory of Ukraine
it is our duty as the general assembly
to vote for the resolution before us and
against the Amendments proposed by
Belarus we need to show our strong
support for Ukraine its sovereignty and
territorial integrity
support for peace
support for peace and the Very
principles of the U.N Charter must be
achieved in this room today
when you and chart are rule-based
international order comes under attack
we must defend it together
thank you very much
I thank the state Secretary to the
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Finland
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Colombia
senior president Mr President Excellence
is
Colombia rejects the use of force
against the territorial Integrity or the
political independence of any country
since this constitutes a clear violation
of the fundamental principles and
purposes of international law and the
United Nations Charter
likewise we reject any unprovoked
aggression by one State against another
this only entails adverse consequences
for the civilian population particularly
women children and other vulnerable
groups
these consequences include the loss of
life
material damage a shortage of food and
energy and Rising poverty
Mr President in line with our total
peace policy outside our national
borders
the Colombian government calls on the
parties to seek a negotiated peaceful
and Lasting settlement to the conflict
in Ukraine and we stand with the victims
claimed by this conflict thank you very
much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Colombia
and now or no I offer the floor to the
distinguished representative of Uruguay
Mr President
the 24th of February marks one year
since the unjustified invasion of
Ukrainian territory by military forces
of the Russian Federation this led to a
persistent conflict with extremely
adverse consequences not only for the
countries involved but also for the
region and the entire International
Community today Uruguay joins its voice
to that of numerous countries that have
made calls aimed at bringing an end to
the hostilities
Uruguay has spoken clearly in statements
made in previous sessions of the
emergency special session since last
March we have roundly condemned the
military invasion of Ukraine by the
Russian Federation
we've denounced it as a clear violation
of the principles of the United Nations
Charter that all members must not only
respect but also comply with and enforce
on this occasion we urge the Russian
Federation to see six military
operations and stop the aggression
against Ukraine reiterating
withdrawing its forces from Ukrainian
territory as soon as possible both
parties to the conflict must make
their utmost efforts to return to the
negotiating table in order to resolve
their differences peacefully as
stipulated by the United Nations Charter
Uruguay has insistently demanded false
respect for international law and has
recalled that it is illegal to acquire
territory through the use of force or
other mechanisms contravening the United
Nations Charter this rule of
international law provided expressly in
the charter and endorsed by the general
assembly the security Council and the
jurisprudence of the international court
of justice means that territorial
annexation in the context of aggression
by one state is a violation of the
charge of our organization and of
international law consequently the
Uruguay government reiterates its Firm
support for the sovereignty and
territory Integrity of Ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
for these reasons Uruguay has
co-sponsored and will vote in favor of
the draft resolution
before us in this meeting of the general
assembly
which contains a resounding call for the
violence to be brought to an end and for
just and Lasting peace to be restored in
this context I wish to recall that the
rejection of the use of force and the
peaceful supplement of disputes are
fundamental principles of Uruguay's
foreign policy finally we reiterate our
call so that through the negotiating
mechanisms provided it by in the UN
Charter with the participation of the
security Council and Secretary General
avenues for dialogue are found to make
it possible to agree on the next steps
to de-escalate the conflict and so that
through diplomatic negotiations the
parties to the conflict can resolve
their differences and bring an end to
the wall thank you very much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Uruguay
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of China
[Music]
Mr President
one ear into the Ukraine crisis
the conflict is still granting all and
growing in scale
wreaking havoc two countless lives
a spillover effect is intensifying we
are deeply worried about this China's
position on the Ukraine Christ issue is
consistent and clear the sovereignty and
territory Integrity of all countries
should be respected
the purposes and principles of uncharter
should be observed
the legitimate security concerns of all
countries should be taken seriously all
efforts conducive to a peaceful
resolution of the crisis should be
supported under the current situation I
wish to share the following Four Points
first
the top priority is to facilitate
ceasefire and cessation of hostilities
without delay conflicts and Wars have no
winners the longer the brutality
the Equator the human suffering
we once again call on the parties to the
conflict to remain rational restrain
their impulses and prevent the crisis
from getting worse or even out of
control
the parties to the conflict should
strictly abide by International
humanitarian law avoid attacking
civilians and civilian infrastructure
protect women children and other victims
of the conflict respect the basic rights
of prisoners of War
all parties should strictly abide by
nuclear safety conventions and a guard
against man-made nuclear accidents
nuclear weapons cannot be used nuclear
war cannot be fought all parties should
join together against the youth or
threat of use of nuclear weapons prevent
nuclear proliferation and avoid a
nuclear crisis
second
dialogue a negotiation is the only
viable way to resolve the Ukraine crisis
at the beginning of the crisis Russia
and Ukraine held several rounds of talks
and made important progress regretfully
peace stops peace talks have since
stored the reason behind this warrants
deep reflection
the lessons of History
tell us that crisis however deep can
ultimately be resolved peacefully no
matter how difficult it is the door to a
political solution cannot be closed we
support Russia and Ukraine moving
towards each other resuming direct
dialogue as soon as possible bringing
the legitimate concerns into the
negotiation setting out feasible options
putting an early end to the crisis and
giving peace a chance
third
the International Community should make
joint offers to facilitate peace talks
one year into the Ukraine crisis brutal
facts offer an ample proof that sending
weapons will not bring peace
adding fill to the fire will only
exacerbate tensions prolonging and
expanding the conflict will only make
ordinary people pay and even healthier
price we reiterate our appeal that
diplomacy and negotiation cannot be
abandoned efforts towards ceasefire and
talks must go on the International
Community should create conditions for
this to happen rather than find the
flames and seek self-interest
we urge the country's concerned to stop
abusing unilateral sanctions and long
arm jurisdiction instead they should act
in a way conducive to de-escalation
the International Community should
strengthen coordination of cooperation
in energy Finance grain trade and
transportation and work together to
mitigate these spillover effect of the
crisis we support the UN General
Assembly playing an active role in
preaching differences building consensus
and folding Synergy among member states
Force pursue common security and Achieve
lasting peace security is not the
prerogative of just a few countries when
country security should not be achieved
at the expense of other countries
security posting or even enlarging
military blocks will only undermine
Regional security and drive peace
further away
the final settlement of the Ukraine
crisis hinders on abandoning the Cold
War mentality giving due regard to and
respecting the reasonable security
concerns of all countries thereby
properly addressing their legitimate
security aspirations and advancing the
building of a balanced effective and
sustainable European security
architecture
Mr President as a responsible country
China always stands on the side of peace
and dialogue
and always Advocates peace and promotes
talks
China will soon
issue a position paper on the political
settlement of the Ukraine crisis we said
ready to continue playing a constructive
role in resolving the Ukraine crisis and
bringing about peace at an early date
thank you president
thank the distinguished representative
of China
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
Islamic Republic of Iran
in the name of God the compassionate the
merciful Mr President excellencies
one year after the start of the Ukraine
crisis the conflict still shows no sign
of ending
and the International Community
continues to Grapple with a range of
challenges including devastating
humanitarian consequences of civilians
and serious implication for the global
economy
given this complex and difficult
circumstances it is essential that we
remain fully committed to achieving a
peaceful resolution and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
this must be done in accordance with the
principles outlined in the charter of
the United Nations Mr President
the Islamic Republic of Finland position
on the ongoing conflict in Ukraine has
not changed we are steadfast in our
commitment to upholding the principles
and purposes enshrined in the shelter of
the United Nations including the
principles of sovereign equality and
territorial Integrity of Estates we urge
all parties to fully comply with the
obligation on the international
humanitarian law including thinking
taking constant
precautions to protect civilians and
political
infrastructure facilitating safe and
unfettered access to humanitarian aid
for those in need Mr President
we acknowledge that this conflict is
determinental to both parties as needed
can gain any long-term advantage
to achieve a sustained solution it is
crucial for all involved parties to
abandon their military Ambitions and
prioritize finding a peaceful diplomatic
resolution
by prioritizing dialogue and diplomacy
and addressing the underlying cause of
the conflict we can take crucial steps
toward achieving a solution that not
only mitigates the devastating Humanity
impact but also restore the journal
stability and security
against the spectrop of the increasing
need to end the conflict my delegation
support the idea of leveraging the
secretary General's capacity
as mandated by the U.N Charter to
establish a cross-regional group of
independent competent impartial
countries
the Islamic Republic of Iran is ready to
contribute to this process which could
be critical in facilitating constructive
dialogue and assisting in identification
of solution to the current impasse in
the Ukraine conflict
as the first step we call for an
immediate and comprehensive ceasefire
coupled with the provision of
humanitarian aids to those in need which
should take precedence over all else
Mr President on the anniversary of this
tragic conflict we had hoped that the
rough resolution before us would present
a practical and achievable means to
bring the end
to the conflict consisting with the U.N
mission
unfortunately the proposed text falls
short of the comprehensively and
impartially addressing all aspects of
the issue and fails to acknowledge the
condition and provocation actions that
have contributed to the crisis
moreover the policies and the action
declared by Satan the sponsors of this
resolution raised doubts about the
political will to resolve the dispute
peacefully
these policies and actions on the ground
have only aggravated the situation
rather than promoting a peaceful and
Lasting solution
instead of bringing the member of the
state together the resolution May
further polarize them potentially
worsening the conflict in Ukraine we
believe that any resolution to this
issue must be based on a thorough and
unbiased assessment of the situation and
underlying cause of the conflict and
must consider all relevant factors and
perspectives it is also critical that
all parties involve demonstrate a
genuine commitment to reaching a
peaceful resolution and take concrete
step in that direction in the light of
these concerns our delegation has
decided to abstain from voting on this
resolution nonetheless
we remain committed to working toward
the peaceful and sustainable resolution
of the conflict and we stand ready to
engage in constructive dialogue and
cooperation with all parties to achieve
this important goal Mr President I would
like to address the reference made to my
country by the representative of the
Israeli regime during the general debate
yesterday
indeed Iran phobic campaign and
widespread systematic dissemination of
this information and baseless allegation
against Iran have always been one of the
main elements of this statement by the
Israeli regime in this August body
the Israeli region cannot conceal its
brutalities in Palestine or distract
attention away from its long-standing
malign activities and demoniac policies
in other countries the Israeli regime is
notorious for its atrocities and
apartheid policies against the people of
Palestine and region by targeting and
killing innocent people including women
and children in occupied Palestine the
Israeli religion continues to commit
flatland and systematic violation of
human rights on all Norms of
international
humanitarian law especially the core
crimes of genocide crime against
humanity War crime and crime of
aggression in this regard we strongly
condemn the Israel religions the
centralized attack early on Sunday 19th
February against a civilian Residential
Building in the densely populated
District of the central Damascus
which continued a flagland violation of
international humanitarian law an
endangering Regional and International
Peace and security the International
Community must strongly condemn such
attacks and compel the Israeli regime to
end all acts of aggression against
Syria's sovereignty and territorial
Integrity immediately
possessing all type of the weapons of
mass destruction as well as the most
sophisticated Conventional Weapons the
Israeli regime continues to endanger
peace and Security in the region and
Beyond and at the same time listen lady
defies constant strong international
call to join internationally legally
binding instruments banning weapons of
mass destruction nevertheless it
attempts to portray Iran's Conventional
Weapons capabilities or is exclusively
peaceful nuclear program as a challenge
to the regional the stability as the
president why we reiterate our
commitment to ongoing bilateral
cooperation which Ukraine and Russian
Federation by government categorically
reject unsubstantiated claims that Iran
has transferred unmanned aerial wickets
for use in Ukraine conflict such claims
are nothing more than a propaganda
campaign used by sustained states to
advance their political agenda Iran is
willing to engage in constructive
bilateral Technical and expert exchange
with Ukrainian Express in order to
clarify and substantiated allegation
level against it I thank you Mr
President
I thank the distinguished representative
of the Islamic Republic of Iran
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Romania
Mr President Romania
aligns itself with a statement delivered
yesterday by the
higher representative of the European
Union Mr Burrell on behalf of European
union and his member states
I would like to add some
points in my national capacity
what we wish for on the cusp of the one
year mark
since the start of the Russia's fully
fledged war of aggression against
Ukraine is very simple
peace for the people of Ukraine
victory of principles and values
and one less bloody Conflict for the
world
but what we are still witnessing is very
different
we continue to see
an alarming level of hostilities
with no sign of abatement
with unimaginable sufferings
for the civilian population
and dire and long-lasting consequences
the human rights and humanitarian
consequences
of the Russian federation's aggression
against Ukraine including the continuous
attacks against this critical
infrastructure
are particularly worrying
no less cruel
are reports of the atrocities committed
and the territory of Ukraine for which
we must ensure accountability
discontinued aggression
undermines the core of the rules-based
international order
and effective multilateralism
and remains a matter of concern for the
International Community
the hybrid were
proliferated by Russia
even more intense through fake news
this information and my line
interferences
aims not only to destabilize the region
and the most vulnerable States
as the Republic of Moldova
but also to undermine our Unity Mutual
trust and solidarity
the Russian Federation is testing the
resolve of the world
to stand up for its norms and values
by attacking the basic principles since
ranked Indian Charter
the Russian Federation is a permanent
member of Security Council
is also attacking the very foundation of
the International Peace and security
the stakes of this conflicts are clear
to all of us
and the world has to send a clear
message
there is no justification for bloodshed
destruction
and human suffering
we need the full force determination and
legitimacy of the general assembly to
reaffirm
that International matters
that the charter matters
and that we stand by the rules put in
place for the protection of every single
member state
of this organization
the upcoming vote and the resolution in
front of us
which we must adopt with the largest
possible majority
is an opportunity
to reaffirm our support for Ukraine
and Ukrainian people
and to call for a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine based on the
principles of the U.N Charter and
international law
Mr President
Romania has been at the Forefront of
countering all multi-dimensional effects
of this war since day one
Romania is also fully engaged in
international efforts to end Russia's
impunity
we are also a strong supporter of the
efforts to seek accountability of all
crimes committed in Ukraine
the perpetrators must pay
and our Collective efforts must be
efficient in this regard
as Ukraine seeks the Justice it deserves
we support the establishment of a
special Tribunal for the crime of
aggression
in relation with a situation in Ukraine
Romania has stood by Ukraine our direct
neighbor
during this whole year of the Russian
aggression
a multi-dimensional effort has been
ongoing for the past year
to accelerate the Tracer for around 13
million towns Ukrainian grain I repeat
30 million one free
through Romanian territory
these have reached countries in the
global South
that have been greatly impacted by the
increase in global food prices and that
have been already facing
food insecurity
the Romanian Port of Costanza at the
Black Sea has become the main gateway
for Ukrainian green shipments a real
food Hub at the European level
a direct effort to contribute
to ensure to ensuring Global Food
security
with the same goal we have also
advocated and we hope for a continuation
of the
Black Sea grain initiative
around 3.6 million Ukrainian citizens
have entered Romania so far
among these over 110
000 remains
we have offered humanitarian Aid to
those he needs
we have also set up a humanitarian hub
and all these to reduce the suffering
and help ukrainians
to defend and build their way to peace
Mr President what we all want is peace
this was made clear today and yesterday
by countless delegations
a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace
a piece that does not reward
the aggressor
a piece based on the principles of the
Union charter
which we have bravely stood up for in
the past
and peace in Ukraine cannot be restored
by inaction
as a matter of urgency
the Russia Federation must Reserve its
illegal actions and unconditionally
withdraw its military forces
from the territory of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
and this call is whatever the resolution
before us delivers
we have the power to unite around this
text Romania supports the draft text
is one of the co-sponsors
and calls on the whole year membership
to vote in favor of this resolution for
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine based
on the principles of the U.N Charter
thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Romania
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of The International
Institute for democracy and electoral
assistance
[Music]
Mr President
excellencies
it has been one year since the Russian
Federation launched its illegal war
against Ukraine
one year of aggression
of war crimes of crimes against humanity
one year of brutality against the basic
principles of the U.N Charter
against the promise of democratic Rights
and Freedoms
against the international
rules-based order
and respect for The Sovereign equality
of all member states
one year of death
displacement and Devastation occurring
each day in territories invaded by
Russia and reviewed in areas recovered
by Ukraine
International idea
reiterate its condemnation of Russia's
illegitimate and immoral war against
Ukraine
and urges the immediate and unequivocal
withdrawal of all Russian military
forces from Ukrainian territory
until this occurs
we welcome the adoption enforcement and
continuous escalation of sanctions by an
International Community against the
Russian Federation
ultimately
the responsibility of the Russian
Federation must be addressed in
accordance with General Assembly
resolution 60- 147
and Universal Declaration of Human
Rights
these accountability
is a matter of international law
and rule of law must and shall prevail
we encourage the U.N Secretary General
to continue working to advance ceasefire
talks and to support increased
humanitarian access to the war affected
areas and protection of civilians
the resolution being debated today calls
for a comprehensive just and Lasting
peace in Ukraine
such an objective is inextricably
connected to the Democratic Ambitions of
the Ukrainian people
as International idea has noted
previously this conflict is about
democracy as much as it is about
sovereignty
over many years
and despite many obstacles
ukrainians have repeatedly affirmed
their commitment to democratic values
the result has been steady improvements
across a variety of democratic
indicators
including respect for media freedoms
the fights against corruption
and the conduct of free and fair
elections as measured by International
ideas indices and reports
today
this hard-won progress hangs in the
balance
but let us be clear
ukrainians have chosen democracy
there's a comprehensive just and Lasting
piece in Ukraine
must be a democratic peace determined by
and for ukrainians
support from the International Community
should reflect this Democratic
imperative
among the needs of a post-war Ukraine
democracy support and the defense of
Human Rights will be crucial
excellencies
the outcome of this institutional
process will reverberate far beyond
Ukraine
it is a test of the defense and
rebuilding of inclusive and sustainable
democracy as a guarantor of Rights for
both people and Nations
in this effort we should not lose sight
of the need to enable a path for
democracy to return to Russia as well as
part of securing a lasting and Regional
and Global Peace
we must say clearly
a democratic Russia would have not
Unleashed this tragedy
advancing democracy is the single best
way to build and guarantee Global Peace
ukrainians are putting their lives on
the line every day to defend the values
that we claim to hold
the values of the U.N Charter
of sovereignty human rights and
multilateralism
helping them to preserve a future for
Ukrainian democracy will be our greatest
tribute to them I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of The International Institute
for democracy and electoral assistance
now I give give the flow to Hurricane
Minister for foreign affairs of Germany
foreign
colleagues
45 seconds
45 seconds to get your grandmother to
safety
45 seconds
to make it to the basement
that's how long it takes for missiles
from Russia to hit the city of kharkif
after you hear the serenes
I met teenagers in kharkif in eastern
Ukraine for whom counting to 45 has
become part of their daily life
teenagers grandmothers fathers who want
nothing more
then for this war to end
to have peace
Russia's war of aggression has not only
brought terrible suffering to the people
of Ukraine
this war has opened gaping wounds across
the world
families on all continents who cannot
make ends meet because of rising foods
and energy prices
I think all of them and most of us here
agree on one simple thing
we want the suffering to stop
in Ukraine and worldwide
we want this war to end
we want peace
and the good thing is we do have a peace
plan right here in front of us
called
the charter of the United Nations
its principles which apply to every
state are very simple
serve an equality
territorial integrity
and the non-use of force
that's why the road to pierce is also
very clear
Russia must withdraw its troops from
Ukraine
Russia must stop the bombing
Russia must return to the U.N Charter
each and every one of us here today has
an opportunity to contribute to this
peace plan
by telling the aggressor to stop
by making clear that it's not peace if
an aggressor tells its victim to Simply
give up
that it's not peace if an aggressor is
rewarded for its ruthless violence
This would run counter to the very
essence of our United Nations Charter
it would not mean peace but more
violence
that's why we are supporting Ukraine in
its right to defend itself as enshrined
in article 51 of the UN Charter
I've heard also today some of you who
said that by arming Ukraine we are
adding fuel to the fire
let me ask you honestly
why on Earth would we do that
we did not want this war
we did not choose this war
we too
would much rather Focus every bit of our
energy and also of our money on fixing
our schools on fighting climate crisis
on strengthening social justice
but the truth is
if Russia stops fighting this war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting
ukrainians
and the human suffering would continue
every single day
abduction rape torture
children counting to 45 every single day
to save their lives
the worst global trade of Devastation
would continue inflation energy
shortages
hunger
that's why today's vote is also about
all of our futures
today each and every one of us here has
to choose
to stand isolated we see oppressor or
to unite for peace
to stay silent
or to protect our U.N Charter
so that the charter can protect us
thank you
[Music]
I thank the distinguished Minister for
foreign affairs of Germany
we have heard the law speaker in the
debate on this item we shall proceed to
consider draft resolution a slash es 11
L7
and draft amendments a slash es 11
L8 and a slash es 11 L9 starting with
explanation of vote before the vote at
three o'clock sharp this meeting is
adjourned
foreign